aux manettes ce troisième volet de la
série documentaire de laurent si bien
edouard mon pote de droite un film qui
dit beaucoup de choses de l'homme et de
la fonction de premier ministre on va en
parler avec nos invités roger karoutchi
bienvenue vous êtes vice-président du
sénat sénateurs à l'ère des
hauts-de-seine gilles boyer bienvenue
vous avoir été souvent dans ce
documentaire vous étiez le conseiller
spécial d'edouard philippe à matignon
vous avez co écrit avec lui impressions
et ligne claire et vous êtes aujourd'hui
député européen pour le groupe de la
majorité présidentielle bérengère bonté
bienvenue à vous également vous êtes
journaliste politique et vous publier
une biographie d'edouard philippe que
vous avez intitulé le sioux tum duel
denis bienvenue vous êtes directeur
adjoint de la rédaction de valeurs
actuelles et vous êtes l'auteur de la
vérité sur edouard philippe enfin david
bellamy est également avec nous bien
venu historien spécialiste de la droite
française maître de conférences en
histoire contemporaine à l'université
d'amiens gilles boyer vous retrouvez le
edouard philippe que vous connaissez
dans ce documentaire je trouve que c'est
une des grandes réussites de ce
documentaire détroit documentaire de
laurence et bien sûr edwards et
documentaires au long cours c'est
précisément je trouve qu'on voit le vrai
edwards en tout cas moi survie que je
connais avec tous les moments les
moments public bien sûr mais aussi les
moments de fatigue le quelques gros mots
parfois parce que la vie me prononce
tous dans la vie ils m'ont demandé des
temps donc c'est la grande réussite de
laurent si bien qu'il ya comme ils
l'assument une relation personnelle et
ancien avec les douars d'avoir su
montrer je trouve ce qui est assez rare
dans un documentaire au politique la
vraie personnalité bérengère bonté est
ce que le rend si bien réussi à capter
tout de même des facettes méconnues
d'edouard philippe pour vous un mois je
trouve que le oui le grand mérite de ce
film c'est précisément que ça me tient
une foule de petits moments qu'on ne
voit pas forcément que les journalistes
peut-être qui le côtoient connaissent
mais que le grand public n'a jamais vu
et je pense notamment aux emportements
aux agacements parce que parce que parce
que le face à face entre le pote de
gauche et le pote de droite fonctionne
très bien et qu'il le pousse dans ses
retranchements sur certains sujets on en
parlera sans doute mais ça c'est
vraiment ça c'est vraiment terrible il
ya une opposition de fond une opposition
idéologique entre les deux hommes au
gérant ozzie vous avez découvert quelque
chose d'edouard philippe en en gardant
ce documentaire ah ben moi je
connaissais moins bien certains aspects
privé si je puis dire mais découvert non
sur le plan politique politique dans les
propos tenus ou dans les positionnements
non après il ya toujours parce qu'on est
tous devenus un peu voyeuriste dans
notre époque il ya toujours le côté ah
tiens il s'énerve ah tiens il se
comporte comme ça bon qui peut créer une
proximité c'est pas ça inutile de savoir
ça mais sur le plan des positionnements
politiques
peut-être peut-être à l'extrême fin de
la partie trois bris je pense qu'on en
reparlera
peut-être au travers de certaines
phrases
des regrets
les espoirs
peut-être des positionnements futur on
verra bien mais y en a en tout cas
le film lui-même on n'apprend pas une
position d'edouard philippe sur un sujet
politique différent de ce qu'on imagine
et jusqu ici et vous tu as des nues
quand vous l'avez vu ce troisième volet
attention à ne pas être naïf aussi ce ça
reste un exercice de communication c'est
un homme politique qui sait parfaitement
aussi communiqué est ce que le résultat
est un film qui le flattent qui le sert
ou qui le dessert du cas je pense que
c'est un film qui le montrent de manière
authentique et d'ailleurs c'est un peu
désespérant je pense pour des
journalistes politiques plus classique
mais on voit bien que en fait il ya une
relation de confiance tels entre laurent
si bien et son personnage qui fait qu'il
a même pas vraiment besoin de poser des
questions
délayez ils arriveront alors sinon là en
ce moment tu te sens comment et comme
ils sont en confiance l'un avec l'autre
edouard philippe répond comme il
répondrait à un vrai ami en tout cas
avec quelqu'un qui n'a pas une caméra à
l'épaule et arrière qui n'existe si vous
voulez ça donne on dirait peut-être
qu'ils parlent en off mais en fait en
même temps avec sa fille il ya pas
vraiment de hof ter que ya pas vraiment
de distorsion entre son discours public
et son discours privé sauf que là c'est
les apparats de la communication
justement moi je trouve au contraire
alors à la fin évidemment ça donne une
période toute communication parce que ça
donne une facette de la personnalité des
doors flip puisque un portrait de
l'homme politique et on découvre un peu
l'homme le personnage mais voilà je
trouve que c'est un langage très direct
des scènes brute au sens justement sans
artifice ça montre aussi quand même le
fonctionnement matignon qui est quand
même un endroit très particulier dans
les lieux dans les lieux du pouvoir et
aussi cette bande dont gilles boyer est
un des piliers mais c'est ça qui est
quand même très particulier dans ceux de
son quinquennat vous avez dans aucun
autre ministère et même à l'elysée ce
phénomène avec des gens qui ont
travaillé ensemble pendant des années
qu'ils se sont croisés puis séparés puis
qui se retrouvent dans cet endroit quand
même un peu incroyable qui est la rue de
varenne et donc au sein on le voit très
bien je trouve et l'historien con at il
pensé david bellamy vous qui avez
regardé ce documentaire avec votre
profondeur historique
merci pour la profondeur historique je
vais faire un pas de côté en disant
qu'on a là quelque chose qui est
finalement sans précédent dans l'univers
médiatique du monde politique alors bien
sûr on on peut penser aux documentaires
de raymond depardon sur la campagne
électorale de valéry giscard d'estaing
en 1974 mais c'était quelque chose de
tout à fait différent valéry giscard
d'estaing voulait garder finalement un
souvenir de cette campagne et puis le
film ne devait pas être diffusé
immédiatement et du reste il a fallu
attendre 25 ans pour pouvoir y accéder
donc on a quelque chose là d'unique ce
qui est important me semble-t-il aussi
c'est que le triptyque nous permet de
voir la personnalité du havre dans la
personnalité d'edouard philippe et ça je
pense qu'on ne peut pas comprendre cet
homme sans bien connaître son lien avec
le havre et puis enfin comme d'habitude
duel denis une un des personnages de ce
troisième film c'est quand même l'hôtel
de matignon et je me souviens que douar
philippe m'avait dit un jour que même
lorsqu'il était député ils entraient
très peu à matignon c'est un lieu où le
grand public entre effectivement très
peu on connaît bien les deux chambres du
parlement on connaît même assez bien le
l'intérieur de l'elysée mémé l'hôtel de
matignon reste un lieu assez méconnue
des français et est l'intérêt de ce
troisième documentaire c'est d'avoir
permis aux uns et aux autres de mieux
connaître ce le essentiel de la
machinerie du pouvoir lieux et la
fonction de premier ministre on y vient
dans un instant tout de même gilles
boyer qu'at-il voulu au travers de ce
film edouard philippe iv il espérait un
document pour l'histoire pour lui pour
remettons les choses à l'endroit c'est
pas edouard philippe qui a voulu ce
documentaire mais il a accepté certes il
ya 20 ans laurent si bien commencé à le
suivre à un moment où personne ne le
suivait il a d'ailleurs des centaines
d'heures de rushes à sa disposition
laurence et bien il ya un contrat entre
deux c'est à dire que laurent au film ce
qu'il veut diffuse ensuite ce qu'il veut
il a été maître du montage mais en
revanche lorsqu'edouard lui demande
d'arrêter de filmer ils arrêtent de
filmer c'est ça le contrat est donc au
moment où on a tous découvert ce
documentaire la choisissez 3 or là on
aurait pu infliger aux sénateurs
karoutchi et des dizaines d'heures de
documentaire sur les doors philo mais il
ya c'est ça le contrat de départ donc
c'est vrai que en acceptant la démarche
et en acceptant qu'elle se poursuive
dans des fonctions que personne
n'imaginait à matignon on a c'est une
forme de filiation le premier
documentaire est plus dans l'action sur
la campagne municipale au havre le
deuxième aussi sur la participation
d'edouard philippe à la primaire aux
côtés d'alain juppé ou les apéros
diffusé récemment et ce troisième on l'a
vu et plus intimiste plus cadré parce
que la fonction l'exigent il a vu les
trois volets d'ailleurs et d'or fine et
puis oui oui ça je vous confirme qu'il a
vu les trois valides et non pas validé
l'idée maintenant c'est ce que j'essaye
de vous expliquer c'est à dire que
laurent a gardé la maîtrise éditoriale
de son de son produit et encore une fois
il a il a choisi parmi les centaines
d'heures d'entretiens qu'il a avec
édouard ce qui lui semblait le plus
pertinent et utile avec d'ailleurs une
une montage qui est d'ailleurs assez
esthétique je trouve pour les trois
films ça alors il n'y a pas que l'homme
que l'on découvre dans le documentaire
il y a évidemment la fonction edouard
philippe fait d'ailleurs un petit peu de
pédagogie et il revient notamment sur la
difficulté de satisfaire tous les
ministères c'est au moment de la
démission de nicolas hulot et là il a
une phrase qui a posteriori paraît
extralucide écoutez je me dis peut-être
que dans cinq ans me reprochera peut pas
avoir
augmenter les efforts
dans la recherche médicale parce qu'il y
aura un virus qu'on n'a pas vu venir tu
vois
tu peux prendre le pari là dessus alors
c'est un extrait qui a beaucoup circulé
et qui dit pas mal de choses bérengère
bonté il dit déjà qu effectivement être
premier ministre sait hiérarchiser les
priorités et jamais réussir à satisfaire
tout le monde en fait c'est celle c'est
le monde sait on n'est pas dans le tout
est possible c'est ce qu'il a fait la
formule exacte et il emploie mais c'est
clairement ce qu'il explique de de
matignon et il s'en accommode finalement
et tout au long du film semble-t-il il
explique à quel point ça lui plaît
justement d'aller chercher où sont les
espaces dont quelque chose qui est très
contraint donc c'est sale et c'est ça le
l'exercice du pouvoir sur sur 7 sur
cette séquence du cobp identiques aux
vitz
la lune ou après coup c'est vrai que
c'est quand même assez étonnant moi ça
fait écho pour moi un conseil des
ministres qui a lieu tout début janvier
2020 où il présente ses voeux au
président la république ce qui est de la
coutume pendant le premier conseil et où
il évoque les les épidémies des années
20 des siècles précédents comme et là
aussi il ya quelque chose d'assez de
presque prémonitoire de 1720 2820 de
épidémie aux catastrophes mais il ya une
espèce de malédiction de l'année 20
comme si évidemment qu'il ne sait pas ce
qui se passe à cette époque là le coït
c'est un cas au fin fond de la chine
dont on ne tourne pas mal à personne n'y
prête attention
mais voilà et je pense je pense par
ailleurs que c'est scellier aussi en les
gens qu'il connaît sable le le goût
qu'il a pour le pour l'oeuvre de marc
bloch
l'étranger fait et je pense qu'il a ça
aussi en permanence je pense qu'il a le
pire en tête en permanence un gilles
boyer nous préférons en a peut-être mais
évidemment ce n'est pas comparable avec
la seconde guerre mondiale encore que
mais mais mais je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose de ça aussi cette phrase elle est
extraite d'un moment où et ward écrit au
fond matignon comme une espèce de
tonneau des danaïdes c'est à dire au
fond tout est prioritaire forcément pour
quelqu'un et puis un beau matin il ya
une priorité qui devient la priorité des
priorités en l'occurrence quelques mois
plus tard le coc vide et évidemment à
posteriori on dit mais on aurait dû s'en
occuper avant
mais si ça veut pas été ça ça aurait été
autre chose dont on aurait dû s'occuper
avant donc c est ça illustre je crois
aussi la grande complexité de la tâche
et les dilemmes qui se pose lorsqu'on
est aux manettes et les dilemmes et lé
pari qu'ont fait peut-être qu'en pense
l'homme qui dans l'opposition à edouard
philippe il annonce quelque chose qui
évite mans va se produire et peut-être
un loupé un raté non je pense que
moi je me souviens de la période où
françois fillon était à matignon puisque
j'étais ministre délégué auprès de lui
et donc j'étais à matignon quasi tous
les jours pendant deux ans et demi
on parle toujours du pouvoir
présidentiel ont des sous la vème
république c'est le président qui est la
clé de voûte et c'est ce qui est vrai
mais j'allais dire l'exécution au
quotidien c'est matignon en concertation
avec d'autres ministères et c'est vrai
que
vous ne pouvez pas être à la fois dans
l'exécution au quotidien et être la
pythie de delphes ou madame soleil c'est
à dire que est ce qu'il y aura un acte
terroriste est ce que vous allez avoir
une catastrophe naturelle est-ce que
vous allez avoir une épidémie en réalité
on vous reproche toujours après ne pas
vous y êtes préparé avant même si
personne ne pouvait prévoir du tout ce
type d'événement mais on dit que
gouverner c'est prévoir donc il ya un
équilibre à trouver et les
parlementaires quand ils contrôlent
l'action sont obligés de dire quel
équilibre avez vous trouvé même si on
sait très bien que le premier ministre
n'est pas omniscient et peut pas tout
voir tout savoir à l'avancé mais
qu'est-ce qu'on prépare qu'est-ce qu'on
ne prépare pas sur quels éléments on est
armé où on n'est pas armé voilà je pense
que
quand il a tenu ces propos edouard
philippe évidemment il n'y avait pas
d'épidémie de kobe dans france on savait
déjà qu'il y avait des éléments loin en
chine on nous disait à l'époque que
s'était cantonné en chine et que ça
viendrait pas en europe
vous avez une indication de date avec la
couleur de la barbe à leur bord est bon
c'est bien avant l'apparition du cog
hill et d'ailleurs on a trouvé à
posteriori à la lumière de cette phrase
d des complotistes pour expliquer
regardez ils savaient ils savaient alors
qu'en fait cette phrase a été prononcée
on peut le retrouver je pense c'est
l'extrait est datée dans le film ça doit
être 2019 ou 2000 eux-mêmes 18 c'est un
exemple qui prend oui pour un exemple
mais ce qui est étonnant presque sait
qu'on s'en étonne parce que si vous vous
demandez à un grand patron un un ancien
président des états unis quels sont les
trois défis majeurs démographie va vous
parler de virus il va vous parler de
réchauffement climatique et c est
évidemment que heureusement
qu'aujourd'hui les responsables
politiques nationaux et a fortiori un
premier ministre est capable de pouvoir
un peu plus loin que
l'avant veille ou la date de lundi de la
semaine prochaine mais ça veut dire
aussi qu'être premier ministre david
bellamy c'est forcément décevoir en tout
cas faire des arbitrages qui est sûr le
moment mécontenter qui emploie ans que
l'histoire montrera qu il était
peut-être les mauvais oui c'est un des
éléments essentiels de la fonction de
premier ministre que d'arbitré alors
après lorsqu'il faut arbitrer entre un
ministre important est le chef du
gouvernement ça se passe de l'autre côté
de de la scène mais ce qu'on voit bien
là et d'ailleurs gilles boyer et edouard
philippe l'ont bien signalé dans leur
livre c'est la différence entre
président et est gouvernée et on le voit
très bien dans ce dans ce dans ce
troisième numéro deux aux manettes où il
s'agit en fait de gouverner et non pas
de président et il me semble d'ailleurs
que ce que l'on remarque à la lecture de
l'ouvragé puis en regardant ce
documentaire c'est aussi il me semble
bien là la certaine marge de manoeuvre
tout de même qu'avait edouard philippe
comme chef du gouvernement il n'est pas
de ces chefs de gouvernement me
semble-t-il lorsque l'on on revient aux
21 qui l'ont précédé qui n'était qu'un
simple collaborateur du chef de l'état
ça je pense que c'est un élément qui me
paraît important et puis on voit la
difficulté du quotidien tout le monde se
souvient de la belle en quête de
raphaëlle bacqué really à plusieurs
années qui avait parlé de l'enfer de
matignon alors edouard philippe dit
qu'il n'a pas vécu cela comme un enfer
parce que précisément ils aiment être
aux manettes mais c'est un endroit où
effectivement long et chaque jour
submergé de décisions à prendre et où
l'on sent le tragique de l'histoire me
semble-t-il un jugement fait sur la base
de ce que vous dites et qui est comment
dire évidemment pas contesté mais je
suis pas d'accord avec vous sur une
chose c'est que évidemment que dans
l'impression et ligne claire le coeur de
l'ouvragé tourne autour de différentes
entreprises et gouverner mais justement
je trouve que dans le long aussi bien
c'est un moment de dézoomer c'est à dire
que les français ont vu pendant trois
ans edouard philippe gouverner parce qu'
il allait voir un accident de car parce
que ils étaient responsables de sa
majorité parce qu'il était happé par
justement l'actualité du quotidien mais
on sent que quand laurent si bien rêve
dans son bureau c'est des moments où
justement un peu la poussière retombe la
caméra des zooms
sur sa vie entre guillemets et c'est là
où justement il ya de la prospective et
c'est là où il ya des lignes de force
qui se dégage est là oui c'est là il a
réfléchi et c'est là sans vouloir mater
d'enfield dans l'embarras justement il
se présidentialise certaine manière
c'est à dire que il voit ya six mois je
trouve que dans le lent aussi bien c'est
là on voit des visions alors que son
rôle de premier ministre au quotidien ne
s'était pas d'expliquer de sa vision
s'était appliqué celle d'emmanuel
m'accrocher karoutchi n'est pas majeur
je suis pas tout à fait comme moi je
n'ai vu que le 3 mai on voit un homme
qui gouvernent qui est obligé de prendre
des décisions heure à heure qui est sous
la pression en fer de matignon
battrait pas tous pour y aller si
c'était un enfermement irrespirable mais
non mais en revanche moi qui est bien
connu par exemple françois fillon à
matignon françois fillon et avait par
rapport au président sarkozy une espèce
de décalage nettement supérieure à ce
qu'elle décalage entre edouard philippe
et emmanuel macron c'est à dire que on
voit dans le film à edouard philippe lee
qui évidemment sous la pression mais qui
n'est pas ce qui était souvent le cas de
françois fillon en désaccord avec la
politique souhaitée par nicolas sarkozy
sur certains sujets pas surtout
évidemment mais sur certains sujets moi
j'ai des souvenirs très précis de
conversation ou françois fillon disait
non là dessus franchement je suis pas
d'accord et où on n'a pas le sentiment
qu'ils aient eu entre edouard philippe
emmanuel macron ce type d'épisodes j'ai
pressenti jusque là on a l'impression
qu'il a versé que on a le sentiment dans
le film avec toute l'estimé que j'ai
pour edouard philippe mais qu'il a pris
dès le départ son rôle de premier
ministre comme
j'exécute si je puis dire la politique
décidée orientée par le président de la
république je ne suis pas là pour être
une force politique autonome différentes
donc le souhaite laurent une tonalité
l'actuel autonomie intellectuelle c'est
pas politique c'est c'est peut-être une
des limites du film que je trouve par
ailleurs excellent mais mais précisément
il dort fille plus que beaucoup d'autres
hommes politiques et femmes politiques
ne parle pas de sa relation avec le
président et donc est donc très peu moi
je sais pour en avoir parlé avec laurent
si bien qu'ils ont ils tentez ils ont
tenté d'en parler et en fait on est bon
on arrête on avait un résultat qui était
très convenue et qui n'avaient ils ne
voulaient pas là et s'en mêle et donc en
fait tout ça est parti au montage est
gérable donc donc ça n'apparaît pas la
relation avec le président n'a pas rêvé
dans l'impression visuelle c'est pas
vraiment un sujet qui est extrêmement
des layènes non plus la relation avec le
président en tant que dogme je vais dire
ce soit voulu s'entendre non mais
d'ailleurs moi j'ai pas le même jeu
coupe à vous livrer que roger karoutchi
celui que roger karoutchi vient de nous
livrer sur les relations entre une fois
la sarkozy et françois fillon groupe
limité quand même non mais écoutez on a
beaucoup écrit par les 10 sur le couple
exécutif depuis 60 ans je n'ai rien lu
ou entendu de différends sur les
relations entre emmanuel macron et loire
philippe que ce que j'entends surtout
leurs prédécesseurs depuis 50 ou 60 ans
c'est le couple exécutif
edouard philippe à une singularité c'est
qu'il a été nommé premier ministre sans
être l'émanation de la majorité qui a
fait élire le président sans avoir fait
sa campagne et sans avoir contribué à
l'élaboration de son projet c'est une
singularité et c'est aussi l'originalité
et l'audace du président de la
république élu et donc comment edouard
philippe pourrait-il arriver à matignon
avec un autre objectif que celui de
mettre en oeuvre le projet bâle campagne
et si il ne s'était pas identifié à ce
projet il n'aurait pas accepté d'être
premier ministre donc c est il refuse en
effet et je crois que
ça peut être frustrant pour certains
d'entre vous mais je crois que c'est un
bon principe de relater ses
conversations avec le président de la
république ou d'émettre un jugement sur
leur relation qui est une relation de
nature professionnelle extrêmement
spécifique qui n'a pas d'équivalent dans
aucun autre milieu et qui je dois
pouvoir je crois doit pouvoir garder sa
part de secret d'ailleurs son seul
pierre françois fillon s'est bien gardée
d'ailleurs de faire état publiquement
des désaccords dont vous faites état
allez vas y à eut
cassé velours j'ai quelques souvenirs de
bofa beau mais c'est bien la difficulté
si si je puis dire si on fait un peu de
prospective
si on se contente pas de diaba sait très
bien ce documentaire personnellement il
est ravissant etc c'est que
si on met on attend beaucoup enfin on
attend beaucoup on attend beaucoup de ce
genre de documentaire de savoir ce que
pourrait être une initiative un chemin
nouveau une définition de quelque chose
pour l'avenir parce que c'est ce que
vous attendez vous mais moi j'attends et
amusez-vous diffusée
mais vous diffuser des documentaires
forcément on se dit pourquoi un
documentaire sur edouard philippe plus
d'un an après qu'il ne soit plus premier
ministe sinon parce que les choses se
prépare parce qu'ils envisagent encore
des choses et un moment ça sort quelques
jours avant lancement d' une formation
regroupant des élus autour de lui donc
forcément se dit et pour quoi faire et à
partir de ce documentaire on ne sait pas
parce qu'en réalité comme vous allez le
faire les corrections va y venir la
fréquentation d'avenir bien des jeux
parle que du documentaire après
j'imagine que gilles c'est des choses
qui va nous dire mais le dans le
documentaire vous ne pouvez pas dire sur
telle ou telle ligne politique ou le
désaccord ou les quarts où l'accord avec
emmanuel mâcon veut dire que s'ils
avaient une initiative edouard philippe
ce serait dans tel sens et vous pouvez
pas de sortir ça du documentaire alors
en tout cas je ne sais pas si c'est
l'enfer matignon mais le premier
ministre c'est évidemment gérer des
crises edouard philippe a dû affronter
l'une des plus graves de notre histoire
récente c'est celle du co vide dans le
documentaire il explique à quel point ça
secoue écoutez c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment j'ai un peu l'impression d'être
tu sais je conduis un car j'ai des
mondes derrière
il ya un train sur deux qui fonctionne
pas il ya du brouillard et du et du
verglas et on est dans une route de
montagne et ta ta ta ta cinq titres dans
le car qui disent mais non il fallait
tourner à droite il fallait tourner à
gauche et puis tous les autres qui
dispute un gta qui va pas se planter
quoi bon ça semble tout face à ben jawad
en ce moment évitez les miss et ça
l'enfer de matignon à écouter ça n'est
tout de même pas c'est un enfer sur le
moment effectivement là on voit bien au
visage que la chose est extrêmement
difficile mais là c'est une crise qui
est particulièrement spécifique
aucun chef de gouvernement n'a connu
quelque chose d'équivalent en tous les
cas depuis vingt 20 25 ans bien sûr il y
à l'époque de la guerre d'algérie avec
michel debré ou où il y a aussi le
tragique de l'histoire comme je disais
il ya un instant qui est présent mais là
on a véritablement à faire à quelque
chose de à quelque chose de spécifique
sans aucun sans aucun précédent et de
fait la la machinerie elle se fait elle
se fait à elle se fait à matignon et je
le disais c'est un des éléments
importants de de ce2 ce2 ce reportage
que de montrer que si les choses peuvent
être décidées orienté au palais de
l'élysée est bien le travail au
quotidien se fait à matignon il ya nos
personnalités considérable à matignon
qui est aussi très discrète et et dont
on parle un peu plus dans les ouvrages
que dans le documentaire c'est le
secrétaire général du gouvernement et et
tout ça fait partie du travail quotidien
de cet endroit qui est qui doit être
découvert par les français comme un un
des lieux les plus importants de la delà
de l'organisation et de l'avis du
gouvernement du pays on comprend dans
les propos d'edouard philippe gilles
boyer s'est aussi qu' il nous dit au
fond on n'a pas été aidé par les
oppositions on dit tourner à droite on
dit tourner à gauche est-ce que ça a été
aussi ça et c'est ça matignon c'est ne
pas être accompagné en tout cas dans une
crise aussi grave jeu bon je pense pas
qu'ils parlaient particulièrement des
oppositions en l'occurrence il parlait
on explique aussi dans notre livre que
dans ces moments là on reçoit des
conseils incomplet contradictoires
partiel qui sont souvent contredits par
les événements du lendemain et que c'est
très difficile de prendre des décisions
éclairées lorsqu'on n'est pas soi-même
outillés lorsqu'on n'est pas soi-même
scientifique ou médecin c'était plutôt
ça je crois qu'ils étaient était évoqué
l'opposition s'est opposée elle avait
bien il avait bien ce droit là quand on
quand on gouverne gouverner c'est
difficile mais c'est passé par l'enfer
mais c'est difficile on prend des
décisions
edwards est un homme d'exécutif il aime
bien être aux manettes il aime bien
prendre des décisions même quand c'est
difficile et c'est aussi gratifiant de
gouverner avoir l'honneur de gouverner
la france dans un moment difficile celle
stimule ou paas elle stimule il ne
déteste pas ces moments là mais enfin ce
genre de choses auxquelles réfléchit
après vous savez parce que quand on est
pendant un an et dans l'action tous les
matins on se demande parce qu'on a on se
demande pas comment on s'appelle on se
demande pas si c'est difficile mais
c'est de passer la journée c'est de
prendre les bonnes décisions pour la
journée qui arrivent dans des crises
comme celle là qui évolue à l'époque
tous les jours c'est seulement après
qu'on peut réfléchir évidemment ce n'est
même plus le temps de réfléchir non mais
ça c'est
étonnant je dis ça roger karoutchi qui a
exercé de hautes fonctions c'est souvent
le propre des fonctions qui sont très
intenses et et lionel jospin raconté ça
dans un documentaire célèbre sur sa
campagne présidentielle de 2002 l'avant
lit où ils surchargé de son agenda il
est même plus le temps de réfléchir et
donc c'est vrai que c'est un piège ça
peut être un piège mais le paradoxe moi
je trouve que il a l'air plus marqué au
moment dé gilet jaune
dans le documentaire d'aussi bien que au
moment de la pandémie qui est je ne dis
pas que c'est un petit sujet la pandémie
mais pour deux raisons
d'une part comment dire au moment des
jets des jaunes il est assez neufs en
tant que premier ministre un poste qu'il
ne l'imaginait pas pouvoir exercer
quelques années plus tôt voire même
quelques quelques mois plus tôt ça lui
tombe dessus et au moment de la crise du
crâne et virus et d'ailleurs je crois
qu'il l'a dit à l'époque un son
entourage heureusement que ça arrive
maintenant d'une certaine manière c'est
à dire avec trois ans d'expérience
derrière moi parce que je sais un peu
plus sur quel bouton appuyer je sais un
peu plus sur qui m'appuyer et c'est à un
moment où
vraiment de manière jédir contre
intuitive mais edouard philippe se
révèle c'est à dire que souvenez vous à
l'époque
à la télévision il avait trouvé le ton
tout le monde finit à quel point c'était
à la fois
pédagogique un peu modeste plus terre à
terre que les intentions présidentielles
qui partait dans les hautes sphères du
monde d'après et dans des élucubrations
parfois un peu métaphysique et lui on a
retenu je ne sais pas on a retenu le
décourage le découragement natale
n'appartient pas la gamme des émotions
que que je m'autorise et donc j'imagine
qu'ils devaient très peu dormir à
l'époque c'était très compliqué mais en
même temps il pour rebondir sur ce que
vient de dire gilles boyer c'était
tellement un moment d'exécution absolue
que on sent aussi qu'il est quelque part
sur son terrain c'est à dire celui de la
prise de décision quel formidable
documentaire c'est évidemment le non
verbal et cette période la 2d gilet
jaune moi je pense à un moment
particulier où il a cet échange avec
laurent si bien sûr la dette par
et là pour le coup on parlait milliards
entre guillemets commencent à sortir et
lui c'est pas dans son logiciel pas
quelque part ça commence sérieusement à
lui poser souci et se pense que c'est à
travers ce genre de moments là même si
je disais tout à l'heure qui ne parle
pas de ses relations avec emmanuel
macron qu'on sent quand même réellement
que qu'il est obligé de jongler entre la
volonté de voilà d'un président les
engagements une situation qui est qui
est compliqué et en fait ça c'est très
visible john et sa vis-à-vis de
moi je pose sans vouloir parce que c'est
un peu différent quand même la caisse
des gilet jaune pour un premier ministre
je dis pas que c'est du banal mais c'est
presque du classique crise économique
crise sociale pour tous tous les
gouvernements ou presque en ont connues
manille fait divers en puissance oui
mais manifestation eu des crises
poujadiste en france des 68 des machins
il y en a eu et donc je comprends qu'un
premier ministre en exercice soit
d'autant plus tendue que boy à la
contrainte financière il ya la
contrainte classique de la dette et
comment répondre à une demande à une
inspiration de la société française dans
ses profondeurs où ces difficultés ou
s'est fracturé en revanche
l'épidémie si la pandémie
jeu mais je suis le premier à dire pour
un premier ministre
qui disent je veux dire à la pandémie
c'est pas une crise normal c'est une de
jour en jour les scientifiques pas
toujours d'accord entre d'ailleurs vous
disent qu'il faut faire mais vous n'êtes
pas dans la même seringue que par
rapport à une crise économique et social
classique en revanche après
malheureusement malheureusement l'espèce
de judiciarisation de la vie publique
fait que votre ministre de la santé se
retrouve devant la cour de justice la
brique un moment d'ailleurs c'est pas le
lieu c'est pas le moment d'être
auditionnés à jouer bien sûr un mode
histoire aux jeunes est aussi là dessus
parce que si matignon n'est pas un enfer
matignon est forcément un lieu de
décision si chaque fois que vous prenez
une décision politique en votre âme et
conscience avec une majorité qui votent
vos décisions
vous pouvez vous retrouver mise en cause
parce que on va dire que cette décision
là ne correspond pas à ça devient
ingérable et c'est un autre sujet
maintenant quel avenir pour edouard
philippe c'est aussi une question on
sait déjà qu'il va soutenir emmanuel
macron pour 2022 il l'a répété à
plusieurs reprises notamment sur tf1
puisqu'il a même confirmé la création
d'un mouvement politique je le cite si
comme je l'espère le président de la
république est élu il aura besoin demain
d'une nouvelle majorité et moi je veux
participer à la constitution de cette
nouvelle majorité de cette nouvelle
nouvelle offre politique ça me paraît
indispensable voilà ce qu'il a confié à
audrey crespo-mara il a redit la même
chose cette semaine sur public sénat au
micro dorian mancini son avenir il a
aussi évoqué dans le documentaire de
laurence y bien regarder
la question c'est qu'est ce que je veux
faire après
le après pouvant être dans deux mois ou
dans deux ans ça change pas grand chose
si ça change ça change des armées mais
intellectuellement ça ne change pas
grand chose qu'est ce que je veux faire
quand j'ai 52 ans ou 50 by
des
quinze vingts années
si dieu me prête vie
que je peux avoir devant moi où je peux
avoir une activité professionnelle
la politique où elle je crois oui
j'ai de l'expérience j'ai 2 qu'est ce
que je fais est ce que je sais ce que je
vaux qu'un cabinet d'avocats avec les
copains je sais faire j'ai déjà fait je
vois là ça peut être amusant et rigolo
est ce que je vais enseigner à
l'étranger j'adorerais ça je pourrais
aussi bien
reprendre ma carrière initiale ou
conseil d'état donné des cours en france
écrire des livres je vous remets retrait
sans doute un petit peu
mais je mets monsieur n'aime pas sur
une analyse ce serait un peu pépère
ouais je sais ce que je dis ce serait un
peu pépère
intellectuellement intéressant bien un
peu
mais je gap à deux il n'y aura pas
beaucoup de jobs ou j'aurais autant
d'adrénaline que
j'ai aussi continuer intense qu ici et
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il a envie de
continuer au plus niveau gilles boyer au
moment où on voit cet extrait c'est le
moment où edouard de décider s'il est
candidat aux élections municipales wavre
et c'est probablement sur le plan
strictement politique la décision la
plus importante qu'il a prise il a en
étant candidat au havre dans un moment
difficile un au moment où premier
ministre était ciblé par ses opposants
havrais a raison ils ont pu y avait bien
droit d'ailleurs il a dit je veux
continuer la politique c'est ça qui l'a
dit ce jour là et ensuite sans savoir si
ce serait un retour au havre immédiat ou
plus plus tardif et donc je sais pas
pourquoi on est surpris en même temps en
connaissant edouard jeu évidemment on
peut on peut sourire en voyant cet
extrait
est probablement que que tu dois le
denier bérengère bonté qui ont écrit des
livres sur lui le savent edouard il a
des jardins secrets qui sont très
puissants il fait pas partie de ceux
qui donc la politique dans la vie
il a déjà fait autre chose peut-être
qu'un jour il fera autre chose mais j'ai
moi j'ai analysé sa candidature au havre
est d'ailleurs tout ce qui s'est passé
depuis comme une manifestation de
détermination a joué un rôle important
dans la vie politique française dans
l'avenir donc quand vous le voyez vous
l'entendez dire cela vous n'êtes pas
surpris vous parce que vous le
connaissez vous savez qu'il a
potentiellement autre chose et qu'il est
très sincère quand il dit qu'il peut
tout à fait génial parce que sans trahir
nos conversations je suis pas là pour ça
il y a beaucoup réfléchi à l'époque
c'est une décision qui n'est pas facile
à prendre et on en a beaucoup parlé et
je sais que
d'autres hypothèses ont été envisagées
mais c'est pour ça que je reviens à la
grande question de l'époque c'était ce
que je suis candidat au havre mais il
n'ya pas que la candidature au havre il
ya aussi la création de ce parti
politique de ce mouvement politique
bérengère disent ils font permettez moi
ce qui me frappe surtout ceux qui
répondent pas il pose des questions en
fait et sait et c'est assez simple mais
c'est vraiment il dort philippe pour moi
là
et c'est ça il se pose lui-même la
gestion permanente écouté avec attention
il ne pose que 10 ne fait que poser des
questions on peut on peut comprendre
qu'ils se les poser qu'il est pas de
réponse définitive mais ça moi ça me
fera ça me fera beaucoup et surtout
qu'on a un début de réponse depuis
pardon mais il crée un mouvement
politique donc il reste au plus haut
niveau et il veut accompagner manuel ma
croix mais à l'époque il se pose des
questions donc il les pose voyez pas ce
que les pros mais il n'a pas toutes les
réponses riz est aujourd'hui peut-être
qu'il a plus de réponse pas tout non
mais non mais parce que la vie est ainsi
faite ça voyez si vous vous demandez à
roger karoutchi qui va faire dans deux
ans bon non c'est pas un
projet avoir des objectifs on peut avoir
des ambitions mais on n'est jamais
certain de les réaliser non mais alors
moi mon métier pas de treillières et
convention est en tout cas c'est de les
relater et évidemment quand j'ai
commencé à écrire le livre en tout cas
allait avoir pour parer d'or philippe et
le poser toutes les questions que
j'avais envie de lui poser et il m'a
expliqué que effectivement il avait
sérieusement envisagé un retour dans le
privé je raconte dans le livre qu'il a
même calculé ce qu'ils pouvaient gagner
à l'époque c'est beaucoup plus que les
émoluments d'un premier ministre ou d'un
modeste sénateurs comme roger kay roger
karoutchi et après ce qui m'a frappé
c'est que
là où je me suis rendu compte qu'il
avait vraiment tranché sur le fait de
vouloir poursuivre en tout cas dans un
premier temps sa carrière politique et
une carte politique sans vraiment plat
de fond de verre c'est que vous vous est
posée à edouard philippe je pense que
c'est arrivé à bérangère aussi n'importe
quelles questions vous pouvez poser un
candidat à l'élection présidentielle ou
à quelqu'un qui a révélation que
s'envisager président de la république
si vous vous demandez edouard philippe
comment la france doit s'intégrer dans
le match entre la chine et les états
unis il n'a pas pas de réponse si vous
vous demandez à être philippe quelles
réformes de structure sont prioritaires
le jour où il a toutes les manettes du
pays qu'est ce qu'il fait il n'a pas pas
de réponse si vous demandez à edouard
philippe s'il assume d'avoir des
ambitions ou si complexe et qu'ils
passent regardent dans le miroir quand
les français lui renvoie dans son regard
je pense que ça reste quand même assez
souvent lorsqu'ils font leurs leur
tournée de rock-stars dans leur
librairie avec gilles boyer il n'ya pas
héros personne qui lui disent monsieur
finale franchement ça serait bien de
vous présenter un jour à l'élection
présidentielle et quand il fonde un
parti politique il rejoint pas le parti
des politiques des manuels macron et
quand il est sur tf1 et qui dit je vais
soutenir le prix dans la république en
2022 parce que à ce jour
politiquement il n'a pas d'autres choix
il dit pas qu'il n'a qu'il abandonne
toute velléité de l'ambition nationale
il dit même que quand on en a il faut
s'y préparer et qui compte bien il
procéder comme ça
sincèrement je pense depuis longtemps
qui retournera pas dans le privé
j'avais eu avec lui sous pas un mystère
de conversation à l'été 2010 9,1 moment
où circuit des idées qui pourraient être
candidats à paris
quand j'ai vu que finalement il était
candidat wavre j'avais dit à mes
honorables collègues du groupe l'est
républicain du sénat
ça veut dire que il prévoit
éventuellement de ne pas rester premier
ministre jusqu'au bout du quinquennat et
qu'il faut qu'il ait une base politique
parce que le meilleur moyen de rebondir
c'est de ne pas sortir complètement du
jeu et d'avoir une base politique
existante et pourquoi pas la mairie du
havre et quand vous avez été premier
ministre
et il l'a fait pendant trois ans
vous avez quand même au dessus de vous
le président la république ces
orientations ses décisions sur les
choses les plus importantes et
franchement quand vous êtes premier
ministre et que vous vous dites j'ai
fait le job qu'il creuse walpole
ministre j'ai fait le job je l' ai bien
fait j'ai mis tout mon coeur j'ai fait
des choses comme il disait j'ai fait le
maximum à un moment vous vous dites
peut-être que si c'était moi qui donnait
en plus les orientations du dessus
ce serait plus facile est en tout cas
j'aime fluhr est plus sur la politique
nationale que ce que je n'ai pu faire à
matignon donc assez logiquement on l'a
vu pour françois fillon l'a vu pour
d'autres et montbard et d'autres assez
logiquement quand vous avez été premier
ministre sauf si vous dit j'arrête la
politique me folio n'a pas beaucoup
beaucoup qui arrête la politique de même
mais
ensuite c'est l'ambition présidentielle
alors pour 2022 il n'y a pas d' espaces
en 2027
il va essayer d'en créer un david
bellamy vous confirmer je crois aussi
que vous travaillez d'ailleurs sur un
ancien maire du havre qui est devenu
président de la république
oui les travaux de recherche actuelle me
portent sur un personnage dont
edouard philippe avec une statuette dans
son bureau au havre et on a vu dans le
troisième épisode qu'elle était arrivée
sur la cheminée de son bureau à matignon
qui est la statuette de rené coty
parlementaire élu président de la
république en 53 il y a eu 22 anciens
premiers ministres à avant lui alors ce
que ce qui s'est passé n'est pas
prédictifs de l'avenir mais
effectivement comme le dit le sénateur
karoutchi c'est une pensée assez naturel
chez les anciens premiers ministres même
s'il y en a quand même cinq ou six qui
n'ont jamais eu l'idée de se présenter à
la présidentielle je pense à couve de
murville par exemple sur les 22 ancien
chef de gouvernement
il y en a une quinzaine qui a envisagé
assez sérieusement d'être candidat à la
présidentielle certains n'ont pas pu
aller jusqu'au bout on citera par
exemple michel rocard qui en avait été
empêché par françois mitterrand à
l'époque on pensa à dominique de
villepin et il y en a huit tout de même
qu'ils ont pu aller jusqu'au bout donc
on élimine ceux qui ont perdu lors des
primaires alain juppé par exemple manuel
valls est sur ces huit anciens chefs de
gouvernement qui ont été candidats à la
présidence de la république depuis
michel debré pompidou chaban chirac
barre balladur jospin et fillon il y en
a deux qui ont été élu président de la
république georges pompidou et jacques
chirac alors là encore je le répète ce
n'est pas du tout prédictif c'est ce qui
s'est passé jadis donc c'est une pensée
naturel de réfléchir à une possible
installation sur l'autre rive de la
seine ce n'est pas une pensée néanmoins
systématique et et jusqu alors ça la
marche est que pour deux anciens chefs
de gouvernement sur les 22 que nous
connaissons que nous avons connu depuis
que la vème république est née il y à
63/100 nous parler pardon de ce parti
est ce que c'est pour se créer une base
de militant-es qu'effectivement c'est
pour préparer ce dont on parle depuis
quelques minutes alors je vous donne
tous rendez vous au havre le 9 octobre
pour ce qui sera pas le congrès
fondateur mais le lancement politique en
effet d'une nouvelle formation qu'a
annoncé
edouard philippe et c'est vrai que
depuis son départ de matignon et en
particulier à l'occasion de la tournée
vous avez la gentillesse de rappeler
suite de la sortie de notre livre il ya
beaucoup de gens qui sont manifestés
auprès de nous et qui
se sont un petit peu orphelin
qu'on parle des lui qu'on parle de
cadres qu'on parle de militants et qu'on
parle surtout des lecteurs des personnes
qui
n'ont pas trouvé dans la recomposition
politique telle qu'elle s'est faite
depuis 2010 est de destination partisane
et c'est toujours dommage en politique
lorsqu'il ya une demande ne pas proposer
d'offres
et donc edwards a annoncé cette cette
initiative qui témoigne en effet comme
il l'a dit lui même et dans des mots qui
sont bien mieux choisie que ce que je
pourrais utiliser comme il l'a dit lui
même de réfléchir non pas à l'élection
présidentielle en elle-même qui est
évidemment décisives mais est ce qui se
passe après c'est à dire qu'est ce qui
se passe pendant les cinq années qui
suivent dans l'hypothèse où président
est réélue avec quelle majorité est ce
que des élections législatives en
porteront les mêmes vagues politiques
que celles qui ont précédé c'est une
question que tout le monde se pose
puisque on n'a jamais été confronté à
cette à cette hypothèse donc l'idée
c'est en effet de fédérer des élus mais
pas seulement surtout des électeurs et
des citoyens pour tenter de faire peser
les grands principes qui doivent
philippe a défendu dans son action
politique depuis aux côtés d'alain juppé
et pour lui-même ensuite alors il ya
cela elle soutient emmanuel macron en
2022 cela ne dit rien de ses ambitions
pour une autre année 2027 à la toute fin
du documentaire oui j'ai peut-être un
peu loin mais laurent si bien pose la
question à edouard philippe edouard
philippe président écoutez sa réponse
là on vit un moment il va revenir des
choses qu'elle revend des chances
deschamps va pas être juste analystes
mais d'abord pas j'ai jamais j'ai jamais
dit j'ai bien écrit nulle part j'ai
jamais pensé que début du commencement
d'une seconde que parce que je partais
de matignon je parte à la retraite de 49
ans
jamais dit que j'arrêtais la vie
politique nationale
mais la meilleure chose
est-ce que tu as tort la pluie comme
sera grande
ouais sauf que moi rigole
[Rires]
bon c'est pas une question légère
il ne répond pas par une question là
bérengère bonté des remarques et non
mais ne répond pas
même si entre les lignes pour moi il
fait aucun d'autres cadors philippe a
envie
l'ambition à un moment d'effectivement
d'exercer ces fonds servent ces
fonctions là ce qui n'est pas le cas
dans la liste tout à l'heure de david
bellamy on n'a pas cité jean castex
l'actuel premier ministre qui dit à tous
les visiteurs qui est qu'il reçoit c'est
en ce moment qui fait comprendre qu'en
gros il est dans le le job le plus
important de sa carrière et que ricco
bonne mais il sera en vacances quoi donc
on n'est pas du tout dans la même
ambition c'est pas systématique c'est ça
que je veux dire edouard philip wee aa
manifestement l'ambition de d'aller
exercer ses responsabilités et d'aller
présider et non plus gouverner pas de
plafond de verre de plafond de verre
comme vous le disiez je pense passer
pour une raison assez simple que
peut-être malheureusement pour eux jean
castex ou bernard cazeneuve vous
d'automne aux premiers ministres actuels
ou anciens premiers ministres n'ont
passé je crois que edouard philippe a
réussi à créer une relation directe avec
les français je vous explique pourquoi
mais surtout c'est ce qui me paraît le
plus important pour la suite de sa
carrière outre ses ambitions
effectivement fonder un parti peut-être
après demain avant un gros groupe à
l'assemblée en ce moment on est beaucoup
dans les journaux pour être prises dans
l'assemblée nationale bon ok très bien
mais ça c'est le quotidien j'ai dit non
de la tête c'est ce que prévoit la peau
peut être tant mieux mais parce que moi
je pense qu'il est plus important pour
lui de rester maire du havre que des
prix de l'ensemble et mais ça c'est mon
petit avis personnel
mais en tout cas ça c'est parce qu'il
faut bien qu il occupe ses journées
maintenant sur quoi il peut capitaliser
les doors philippe bas c'est qu'en fait
c'est l'homme politique politique
préférée des français que vous avez des
dames à serre tête et des jeunes bobos
10e arrondissement qui le trouve très
bien vous avez des des personnages âgées
et des jeunes électeurs qui le trouve
très bien qu'il y fait
la razzia dans l'électorat et l'air plus
que énormément d'aujourd'hui candidats à
la primaire déclaré chez les
républicains il fait une grosse razzia
au centre gauche est en fait à cause de
cette pandémie josé pas dire grâce mais
et du poste de premier ministre il est
complètement rentré dans la tête des
français c'est à dire que tout le monde
le connaît tout le monde l'envisagent et
je crois que maintenant qu'il faut
travailler sur sa personnalité sa
stature le si bien en fait partie je
crois qu'il a des ambitions de
littéraire qui sont pas qu'ils sont pas
comment dire à sécher que il demain il
pourra continuer à écrire et qu'il faut
qu'ils nourrissent cette chose
complètement immatériel et est très
improbable et pourtant fondamentale qui
est sa relation en direct avec les
français donc dans l'intermédiation
départissant de permanisation même de
son mandat et ça ça passera par là
continuer à exister dans l'imaginaire
des français et 2027 n'est pas ''sans
inenvisageable d'autant plus qu'il aura
gardé cette image d' homme loyal parce
qu'il reste loyale gilles boyer à
emmanuel macron ça c'est une de ses
particularités
je vous vois faire l'amour quand j'ai
karoutchi non non oui d'abord je vais
enfin j'ai toujours dit et ce qui s'est
passé récemment m'a pas fait changer
d'avis il doit jamais oublier les
conditions dans lesquelles il a été
nommé à matignon je les ai rappelés tout
à l'heure le brièvement emmanuel macron
pouvait tout à fait nommer quelqu'un
d'autre il aurait été d'ailleurs dans la
nature des choses telles qu'on les
imaginait avant qu'il nomma quelqu'un
d'autre donc edouard philippe ne l'a
jamais oublié il n'a jamais oublié la
qualité de la relation de travail qui a
été noyé pendant trois ans et donc ça ça
ne s'oublie pas et il doit philippe a
résumé sa d'une formule où chacun
prendra ceux qu'il souhaitera c'est
loyal mais libre c'est loyal mais libre
et ça se matérialise aujourd'hui par la
création de cette nouvelle formation
politique qui s'inscrit dans la majorité
présidentielle future je crois que le
problème des grandes interrogations moi
je ne conteste pas les qualités d'homme
d'état d'edouard philippe et sa capacité
à aller à l'élection présidentielle 2027
c'est loin où en sera la recomposition
de la droite où en sera le paysage
politique où on sera l'évolution du
deuxième mandat éventuel éventuels que
je ne souhaite pas d' emmanuel macron
personne n'en sait rien
c'est emmanuel macron est battu par
exemple 2022 le positionnement d'edouard
philippe devient compliqué y compris par
rapport à la droite si manuel macouin
est réélu le positionnement des doigts
philippe reste compliqué parce que il ya
toujours à l'intérieur d'une majorité
présidentielle des gens qui se disent
pourquoi lui et pas moi moi j'étais là
avant moi je l'accompagnais présent fin
personne ne sait c'est long 5 6 ans
personne ne sait ce qui peut se passer
en cinq six ans qu'ils aient la capacité
intellectuelle la carrure
personne personne n'en doute après les
conditions politiques le paysage
politique évolue très vite surtout en ce
moment et donc il faudra voir dans les
mois et les années qui viennent je sais
pas ce que donnera le mouvement
politique lancé en octobre forcément y
aura des gens mais est-ce que ça suffira
à être une secousse par rapport à la
droite établi dans les formations
politiques d'aujourd'hui est ce que les
gens vont pas dire oui ou non mais si
c'est pour finalement aller chez makro
on va voir si vous voyez même roger
karouchi pose beaucoup de questions
beaucoup le temps est long et vous
amener sur la question des partis
politiques des couleurs politiques c'est
l'autre question aussi que pose ce film
celle de la définition de la droite
d'ailleurs edouard philippe est il de
droite écoutez
j'ai le privilège de droite
de votre question toujours de droite
yes tutuelle denis il est toujours de
droite edouard philippe en tout cas moi
je vous cache pas que je travaille dans
un journal classé plutôt à droite et que
donc je lui ai posé des questions de
journalistes plutôt de droite et que ça
satisfera pas l'ensemble des lecteurs de
valeurs actuelles mais l'immigration
les problèmes liés au fondamentalisme
musulman
la gestion des comptes publics
et puis une sorte d'univers personnel
qui peut sonner
et qui peut correspondre à ce que les
électeurs de droite attendre d'un
responsable politique quand on parle
d'art mais avec edouard philippe
quand on parle d'autorité et même si
j'allais dire qu'on parle de religion
est ce qu'il est complètement athée non
croyants en tout cas est en revanche on
avait eu une discussion assez rigolote
il se trouve que moi j'ai un frère prête
donc je vais demander un peu ce qu'ils
pensaient de ce qui est devenu la
religion catholique en france il m'a dit
un truc pour moi éminemment de droite
montre quelques des gens de droite qui
peuvent dire ça c'est que depuis le
concile vatican ii il trouve que les
mets se ressemble plus à grand chose est
en tout cas que la guitare à la messe
n'est pas du tout pas du tout sa came
que pour lui le religieux est soit très
sobre soit très pompeux mais que c'était
sa définition du sacré donc pour moi
être de droite c'est aussi ça c'est à
dire un espèce des tos et d'univers
culturel qui qui rend qui renvoie ça
après je sais aussi que c'est quelqu'un
qui est obsédé par la nuance un peu trop
à mon goût et qui
est il veut absolument pas avoir des
phrases définitives juste jolie sur les
salaires l'édition la définition sa
famille politique mais après si vous le
mettez en débat face à eric zemmour
beaucoup trop longue et régler moi tout
ce qu'ils ont fait des plus beaux des
mères en germant il est
incontestablement de droite de mon point
de vue aussi il n'a pas toujours été
encore que et le face à face l'ont si
bien edouard philippe est intéressant de
ce point de vue là ils se sont connus à
une époque où il était au poker de
gauche tous les deux sauf que l'on rend
si bien été candidats sur des listes de
pierre juquin et que de voir philippe
était plutôt car dans son cas mendes et
c est que et que dans l'esprit de
laurent si bien c'était absolument pas
un homme de gauche donc bon c'était de
la gauche qui à ikea qui a commencé
glisser vers
vers vers le centre vers la droite mais
c'est assez clair sur sa sur son sa
perception ils sont mon ambition en
termes de dépenses publiques c'est une
obsession absolue dans dans la
gouvernance et s'il accepte un jour ce
sera évidemment le rail principal moi
j'irais même plus loin en tout cas pour
moi ya pas de ya pas de doute et même et
si je trompais pardon plus globalement
c'est un homme de la norme c'est un du
droit c'est un conseiller d'état s'est
il ya quelque chose de cet ordre là dans
cet ancien conservateur
est-ce que pompey ce qu'on peut dire
conservateur oui probablement là moi
j'irais même plus loin en disant que son
avenir est à droite c'est à dire que pas
forcément en rejoignant les républicains
et c'est
de ça mais quand vous regardez roger
karoutchi sans qui je parle oui mais bon
le pauvre roger karoutchi la compagnie
les derniers pas les derniers pas d'une
formation politique
mais si si si vous aussi vous voulez
quand vous regardez tous les sondages
d'opinion tous les signaux faibles du
positionnement la société française la
société française dans sa grande
majorité est plutôt de droite même si ça
se voit pas forcément
de droite et refusé le relativisme moral
s'est refusé l'affaissement des moeurs
est refusé l'autorité a feinté robuste
et que l'autorité du policier du
professeur du magistrat soit contesté
s'est refusé que la dette soit quelque
chose qu'on jette par dessus des pôles
ont la dent
objectif
du parti de droite the objective c est
votre conception de la droite ça n'est
pas la mienne et moi j'ai toujours été à
droite depuis que je me suis engagé en
politique que derrière à l'époque
georges pompidou puis là sur le
relativisme ans je ne sais même pas ce
que ça veut dire donc ne m'ennuyais pas
avec des considérations philosophiques
j'essayais de droite
pourquoi voulez vous que ça me fasse
parce qu'il n'est pas dans votre camp
politique
on n'a jamais caché qu'en 2017 un
certain nombre d'hommes de femmes de
droite qui étaient avec nous jusqu ici l
ump ou aux républicains sont les schémas
gonflé de la droite au départ tout
autant
ils sont de droite ils ont rejoint
macron c'est leur affaire ils ont pas
d'un coup
fait une peinture pour ne plus être de
droite qu'on considère nous que rentrant
dans le système macron il abandonne
forcément en tout cas dans l'exécution
un certain nombre de valeurs auxquelles
nous tenons parce que c'est pas possible
de dire je suis de droite mais par
définition je suis avec ma con donc je
peux pas faire je prends le cas
quelqu'un non mais je prends le cas par
exemple de quelqu'un que j'aime beaucoup
avec qui j'ai beaucoup travaillé avec
nicolas sarkozy gérald darmanin chaque
fois que je l'entends au sénat venir
parler de sécurité d'immigration de
droit d'asile je me dis ce type il est
de chez moi sonepar mais il s il est de
chez moi mais le problème c'est que
ensuite tel discours puis à l'exécution
et l'exécution ne va pas parce que comme
en réalité le camp macron n'a pas de
majorité correspondent à ce discours à
l'assemblée nationale vous pouvez avoir
les meilleurs discours de la terre sur
le droit d'asile sur la sécurité sur
l'immigration sur l'identité sur la
culture c'est pas ce qui se passe donc
pas ce que feront tati alors pourquoi
l'aimez pas ce arabe parce que ces
hommes de dragan hier la queue en 2017
reconnaissons que nous nous avions déjà
perdu 2012
nous n'étions pas très bien on peut le
dire comme ça parce qu'on n'était même
pas au deuxième tour en 2010 est
forcément un certain nombre d'hommes de
droite qui se disait plutôt être au
gouvernement et à l'exécution des choses
qu être encore et encore dans
l'opposition ils ont peut-être cru
qu'ils allaient pouvoir plus influencé
que ça emmanuel macron et le conduire à
faire des choses qui n'ont pas réussi à
faire sinon sinon il y aurait même plus
de droite parce que si la droite entre
guillemets ayant rejoint macron avait
conduit macron être beaucoup plus dans
l'exécution à droite mais il aurait
aspiré nos électeurs complètement il
aurait aspiré les parties l'ami l'année
parce que le mcs reçoit une impasse
politique et que finalement ne
satisfasse pas le vrai électeurs de
droite on est complètement d'accord mais
ça n'empêche pas que edouard philippe et
d'une certaine manière un symptôme de la
crise l'existentiel des républicains
puisque vous avez d'un côté eric zemmour
qui polarise une partie des électeurs
avec un discours identitaire beaucoup
plus d'affirmer que n'ose le faire
d'autres responsables des républicains
et de l'autre côté edouard philippe qui
lui incarne la droite de gouvernement
deere classic beaucoup mieux que xavier
bertrand plus valérie pécresse qui
chaque semaine donc si david bellamy que
ces tendances de droite effectivement
incarné par edouard philippe incarner
peut-être par eric zemmour incarné par
xavier bertrand valérie pécresse la
droite a toujours été plurielle a
évidemment dans l'histoire mais enfin
est-ce qu'elle l'a déjà été à ce point
je vais finir par vous lasser rebecca
fitoussi puisqu'à chaque fois que j'ai
le plaisir de venir sur votre plateau je
vous répète que la droite n'existe pas
mais qu'ils y aillent historiquement des
droites effectivement et c'est
d'ailleurs ce que chacun d'entre nous a
finalement dit dis ici aux aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on prend le livre de gilles boyer
et et voir philippe pache 291 voilà ce
qu'ils écrivent notre culture politique
empreinte de libéralisme tempéré
d'admiration gaulliste et de respect
anciens pour la culture social démocrate
libéralisme admiration pour le gaullisme
et respect pour la culture social
démocrate si edouard philippe est un
homme de droite c'est un homme de ce
qu'on pourrait appeler la droite modérée
c'est-à-dire finalement cet espace
politique qui bougent depuis 2010 est au
tour d'emmanuel macro et donc il ya là
une logique à la fois partisane à la
fois intellectuel à la fois humaines en
tous les cas ce qui est certain c'est
que edouard philippe n'est pas un
idéologue
gilles boyer
je crois que notre débat illustre au
fond que ça dépend beaucoup à qui vous
posez la question voyez pas ce que pour
le rend si bien edouard philippe c'est
son pote de droite
si vous journalistes de libération il
vous dira probablement la même chose un
journaliste de valeurs actuelles vous
dis la même chose ah non vous dit le
plus tôt oui oui enfin avec des nuances
qui est au fond mais on s'est beaucoup
le propos je trouve donc mais je pense
que pour les lecteurs de valeurs
actuelles disons edouard philippe n'est
pas assez à droite
et donc j'ai assez envie de laisser ce
débat à d'autres parce qu'au fond c'est
le débat du début du quinquennat est ce
que la politique menée est une politique
de gauche la gauche vous dirais que non
la droite vous direz quoi bon est ce que
c'est une politique de droite roger
karoutchi trouvera sans doute que non et
pourtant je vois qu'il ya de nombreux
électeurs de la droite et du centre qui
au fond approuvé globalement ce qui a
été fait
pendant ce quinquennat mais quelle est
la réponse pardon quelle est la réponse
est ce que c'est un homme de droite
est-ce que c'était une politique de
droite gauche mais puisque vous y étiez
à ce que je peux vous dire c'est qu'à
aucun moment edouard philippe ne s'est
senti mal à l'aise avec les décisions
qui ont été prises ou qu'il a prises ou
mis en oeuvre même par exemple la
suppression rapide de l'idf
à oui je peux vous tout à fait vous dire
ça mais je peux tout à fait en tout cas
c'était dans le projet présidentiel au
moment de l'élection présidentielle
donc le président a été élu notamment
avec cette proposition et si edouard
philippe ne voulait pas la mettre en
oeuvre n'aurait pas accepté d'aller à
matignon
mais rassure que d'ailleurs la
suppression des aides soient
déterminants détruit un margairaz que
nicolas sarkozy n'a jamais voulu
complètement supprimée lisf on a mis des
mesures l'intermédiation mais pas de
suppression c'est pas ce palier sf qui
est déterminant de savoir si on est de
droite ou pas comme des anges est
remontée ce qu'un espace politique pour
cette droite que veut incarner et de re
fini puisqu'il se dit de droite encore
une fois ce sont ces mois c'est encore
un peu flou un ce que ce qu'ils disent
qu'il cherche à incarner on est sûr
si on regarde par exemple cette
république des mères vous savez qui
s'est créée puis kiki qui est issu en
fait de la primaire d'alain juppé en
tout cas de l'équipe qui soutenait alain
juppé qui a beaucoup accompagnés de
leurs philippe à matignon et puis qui
continue à le suivre qui d'ailleurs le
rassemblement durable dont on parle et
j'ai envoyé le 8 et 9 octobre c'est
c'est encore autour de ça et là on a une
idée un peu deux pas de l'endroit où on
se trouve mais si je comprends bien le
parti politique il a le mouvement ou
enfin quel que soit son nom il aura pour
vocation de rassembler d'autres
tendances de de cette majorité un peu un
centre droit
en creux ni avec un coeur d'un coeur
pour edouard philippe qui est au centre
droit mais qui peut être assez large
mais moi je vais vous laisser pas quand
je vais vous laisser ce débat d'accord
je vais vous laisser qualifié souk
edouard philippe et je vais vous laisser
parce que je pense que c'est un piège
voyons passe beaucoup de temps à parler
de ça ces volontés donc ce piège
l'addition ya quand même mais ça s'est
faite le
mais chacun connaît edouard philippe
chacun connaît ce qu'il a fait dans sa
vie ce qu'il a décidé d'où il vient ce
qu'il a vécu aux côtés de qui se
diraient ceux qu'il a exécutée mis en
oeuvre comme politique et donc chacun
peut juger le dit gilles boyer est
extrêmement clair c'est qu'en réalité on
ne sort de l'ambiguïté qu'à son
détriment
et il a parfaitement raison s'il veut
attirer beaucoup de monde autant ne pas
être forcément trop clair dès le début
parce que par définition tous ceux qui
vont pas se reconnaître dans un
positionnement ou un discours risque de
ne pas venir est l'intérêt
je n'irai pas mais l'intérêt de lancer
ce genre de mouvement le 9 octobre c'est
d'être up assez floue au départ pour que
les gens se disent il ya peut-être
quelque chose avec un problème qui
n'échappe à personne c'est que vouloir
être
la jambe de droite le pilier droit de la
majorité macro nist ça va poser un
problème d'abord par exemple avec agir
qui voulait qui était déjà sur ce
créneau là est ce que vous en faites pas
ce qu'est agir éléments à huy agir c'est
le mouvement politique a été lancé par
franck riester un certain nombre de
parlementaires pour être informé ce
que je peux ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que le 9 octobre édouard en
présentant son initiative présentera ce
qui à ses yeux sont les valeurs
fondatrices du mouvement qui va créer me
semble tout à fait naturel et normal et
dans ces valeurs je suppose qu'un homme
de gauche il verra pour certaines des
valeurs de droite mais qu'un homme de
droite y verra pour certaines des
valeurs de gauche bon mais enfin est ce
que vous comptez sur le fait qu'il suive
un homme comme ils ont suivi pour ce qui
était de la macro nizon suivi emmanuel
macron ça fera partie ce sera avant tout
l'adhésion à un corpus de valeurs mais
évidemment l'adhésion à une personnalité
politique à une démarche un caractère
une personnalité ça compte évidemment
dans la vème république qui est la nôtre
la question de l'incarnation
ces risques et ces risques et de compter
sur une incarnation
d'ailleurs ce que ce qui est risqué et
ce n'est pas risqué c'est de ne rien
faire je mets ce moment là on fait rien
et puis ça s'arrête
moi je vous souhaite que justement les
gens de droite n'y voit pas quelque
chose de gauche et des gens de gauche
quelque chose de droite parce que on a
le droit aussi en politique à croire à
la politique de l'offre de croire la
politique de la france c'est pas
interdit de pas attendre les desiderata
des uns et des autres est d'arriver au
au contraire avec une ligne claire et
pas forcément que des impressions et de
proposer un projet défini mais viendra
qui vous viendra qui veut mais on
propose une offre viendra kim ou si la
personne
y compris des électeurs de la république
en marge des adhérents dans marche mais
c'est linge c'est tout le mouvement que
nous allons créer se situe dans le cadre
de la majorité et je ne vois pas en quoi
l'appartenance à la république en marche
c'est incompatible avec les valeurs que
edouard philippe henon sera le 9 octobre
par définition je ne pense pas sans
dévoiler de secrets d'état que les
valeurs d'edouard philippe sont
incompatibles avec celles que portent
mouvement de la république en marche si
je peux me permettre il y aura juste une
ambiguïté parce que moi je pense que mes
à cc contre 1 emmanuel macron était
nouveau candidat en 2022 il n'a pas dit
officiellement enfin c'est comme ça et
c'est très difficile pour quelqu'un qui
a été son premier ministre d'être
candidat contre celui qui l'a nommé à
matignon bon loyauté fidélité tout ce
qu'on veut c'est évident que edouard
philippe n'aurait pas eu cette
contrainte de la présidentielle dans
quelques mois et de la candidature
d'emmanuel macron lancer un mouvement il
aurait pu le faire de manière très libre
là où il y aura une contrainte c'est que
comme il a dit je soutiendrai emmanuel
macron 2022 les gens qui vont aller voir
le 9 octobre vont quelque part que
manière évidente être catalogué comme
soutien des manuels mâcon pour 2022 mais
dont la clarté donc c'est une démarche
avec londres donc franchement quand on
va se dire de droite dans l'opposition
c'est difficile d'aller chez doit fait
des prises octobre et j'ai qui fait
l'unanimité qui faire une analyse laisse
david bellamy conclure ce débat peut
être en quelques secondes sur un détail
tout à l'heure vous avez montré la
dernière scène de ceux de la dernière
scène que vous avez montré du
documentaire on voyait loire philippe
sur le sur la plage du havre ou de
sainte adresse
et ne pas répondre à la question
sur son avenir présidentiel
quand j'ai vu cette cette séquence il ya
quelques semaines j'ai pensé à georges
pompidou alors là non plus ce n'est pas
du tout prédictifs mais j'ai pensé à
georges pompidou qui interrogés en
janvier 69 6 mois après son départ de
matignon
interrogé à rome par un journaliste
avait eu cette phrase où il annonçait
qu'après la fin du mandat du général de
gaulle il serait il serait chef de
l'état et cela n'avait fait que creuser
le fossé entre georges pompidou et
charles de gaulle et leur fils il n'a
pas fait cette entre guillemets erreur
vis-à-vis de d'emmanuel macron mais ça
ne veut pas dire qu'il ne se réservent
pas pour l'avenir on s'arrêtera sur
cette référence historique qui en dit
beaucoup merci merci infiniment à tous
les sens et d'avoir participé à cette
émission avant de vous quitter je cite
our sites vos livres l'hôtel de matignon
du xviie siècle à nos jours auxquels
vous avez donc participé david bellamy
impressions et ligne claire coécrit par
vous gilles boyer avec edouard philippe
la vérité sur edouard philippe c'est le
vôtre tugdual denis et le sioux c'est le
vôtre bérengère banques qui sort le 7
octobre merci à vous de nous avoir suivi
et à très bientôt sur public sénat
[Musique]